hi my name is Callie and I'm reviewing
Animal Crossing New Horizons for Dame's
but this is a review in progress because
Animal Crossing is not the kind of game
you can really binge for a review you do
have to take it day by day and as of
this recording I'm on day 13 of my
Island and there's a lot I haven't seen
from staples of the Animal Crossing
franchise to new features that were
advertised mostly terraforming I haven't
unlocked that yet so this will be a
review in progress until I have seen
those things but overall I am really
enjoying it my main concern right now is
just that some things aren't in the game
that I can't possibly know because I
haven't gone there yet so here we go
[Music]
one of the most striking things about
New Horizons right away is that the
island is basically empty when you get
there there's no stores there's just an
airport you and two other villagers
everybody's tense
there's not even a shop so Timmy and
Tommy and Tom Nook all operate out of
one tent together at the very beginning
that doesn't last very long if you play
your cards right but it is pretty empty
at first and you only have access to a
small portion of the map on that first
date just because there's no bridges or
anything it is truly deserted which
helps make that feel way less and lonely
it really does have this emphasis on
friendship and of building a community
up right from the beginning and I think
that really sets the tone for what
you're going to be doing in your
writings so because the island is
deserted there's a heavy emphasis on
crafting at the beginning it's the DIY
system and basically you can find DIY
recipes wash up on the beach in balloons
you can buy some people would give them
to you but regardless how you get them
you have to learn them and then you can
build things using resources you gather
from the island and initially I was kind
of worried about how that system would
incorporate into the traditional flow of
Animal Crossing and it's beginning of
this game it there's definitely a heavy
emphasis on it because you just don't
have anything you you need to craft in
order to unlock things or to get
furniture for your house to get a table
I didn't get a table for a long time
because there's wasn't one at the shop
but as you open things up in the game
the emphasis on crafting kind of weaves
in with everything else so there's
there's not as much resource gathering
that you you have to do but I want to do
it now and I'm having fun gathering
resources and finding new recipes you
can find them all over the place people
give them to you and every time I find a
new recipe I get excited to see what
Allu and what I can craft with it and if
it's customizable if I can change the
color for example the first bamboo
recipe I found clued me into the fact
that there was bamboo in this game and
then when I finally got some bamboo I
was all excited because then I can go
craft that thing and see what it did
which really does fit into what Animal
Crossing is it still is the same waking
up every day seeing what's new finding a
new recipe
learning what that recipe does and then
the next day you actually get the
materials to do that recipe so it
doesn't feel as counterintuitive as I
thought it would and I'm really enjoying
it part of the reason I'm enjoying
crafting is because there's kind of a
slower pace in New Horizons than
previous Animal Crossing games you
really have to work for things and wait
for things to progress and there's still
plenty to do and part of that is because
of the crafting the other part of that
is the new file system which i think is
really really clever it's another
currency you can use to unlock things
including the tool wheel which I love
but the system of earning Nick miles I
think works so well because it's kind of
like achievements for doing things
around your island but it doesn't feel
forced because some of them are
challenging like one that took me a
really long time to do was fishing
catching a hundred fish in a row without
messing up I spent many days trying to
do that but there's also ones like you
get rewarded for making mistakes like
getting stung by a wasp or fainting
because it tranch a little bit you so
you don't have to always be chasing Nick
miles if you don't want to you kind of
just get them from naturally doing
things that you would do around the
island watering your flowers catching
bugs talking to your villagers and so
that system also really complements the
flow of Animal Crossing it just gives
you another reward for doing the things
you would be doing anyway and also a
sense of accomplishment for doing those
things without having to chase them for
some kind of achievement and part of
that is because I don't really have to
grind for enough miles I have so many
nook miles and I spend them all the time
one of the biggest things you can spend
Nick miles on is traveling to deserted
islands other than the island that
you're already on they're much smaller
than your island and they kind of are
random you don't really know you're
gonna get when you go there you can get
an island with a different kind of fruit
than you have you can get an island that
has really rare insects or bugs like I
found one that was just covered in
tarantulas and I farm to tarantulas for
half an hour
and went and sold them the one thing
that is disappointing about the system
to me is unlike new Leafs Island these
islands are still in your same
hemisphere your same
season and so you're not getting stuff
that you couldn't normally get on your
island it's more about the chase for a
rare one with money-making opportunities
or finding a villager that you want to
invite to live in your town I think
about new Leafs Island which you could
go and catch bugs out of season and they
were really rare and really profitable
so you know the the deserted islands are
kind of hit or miss for me I'm finding a
lot of ones that I go and I'm kind of
like uh not a lot here for me and then
some really are exciting and that's just
kind of the gambling you take me you go
but it's still a cool opportunity to be
able to see something for example the
bamboo that I didn't know I could find I
found on an island like that another
thing that's kind of hit or miss are the
new navigation items the ladder and the
vaulting pole both of them are tools
that you can equip and the vaulting Bowl
helps you get over rivers and a ladder
helps you get up cliffs and the
cumbersome part is that even with the
tool wheel which helps you select tools
way faster than you could ever before
it's still kind of annoying to swap
between them especially if you're
cutting down trees or watering flowers
and constantly swapping between two
tools instead of just putting the ladder
or pole away but I do really enjoy the
flexibility of being able to cross my
river wherever I want in a pinch if I
really don't feel like walking all the
way to the bridge I just built that is
nice and it's kind of mitigated because
you can unlock the ability to build
bridges and inclines pretty early on so
if you really don't like using them you
can kind of just fix that for yourself
by building the inclines and bridges
where you would normally be putting up
ladders or using your vaulting pole that
said I really do love exploring the
island not just because I'm looking for
new visitors or doing my typical daily
chores that you do in Animal Crossing
but also because it is so beautiful it
is it is visually more of a treat than
any other Animal Crossing game as you
would expect but the little details
really surprised me and I really just
love observing them like you might have
seen in preview coverage that animals
can
eat sandwiches or carry stuff around and
they have more idle animations sometimes
they send her a tree and take a nap but
I was really surprised to find one of my
villagers singing in the town square I
heard an animal singing and I was kind
of taken aback because this villager was
not necessarily my favorite I wasn't
sure if I liked him but he was singing
the little song in the town square for
like an hour I sat and watched him for a
really long time and other villagers
came up and one of them sat down and
watched him with me and I was just just
take I just didn't expect it and it was
so cute I got really emotional and now
he's one of my favorite villagers that I
have in my town and it's those little
things that draw you into the villagers
even more obviously we all have our
favourite villagers in Animal Crossing
if you've ever played one before you
probably are attached to at least one of
them but I don't have any villagers that
I've ever had before my town and I'm
really growing to love each and every
one of them just because of these little
details on top of their cute little
things they say or visiting their houses
the normal stuff you would do an animal
crossing it's those small idle things
just watching them in the distance that
I am loving so much about new horizons
and on the note of pretty things the
museum pretty much blew me away I was
not expecting the museum to be so
gorgeous I've played every animal
crossing game I've donated my share of
fish and bugs and dinosaurs I was just
not expecting what this museum is I mean
it's first of all it's huge the insect
exhibit is multiple parts well each
exhibit is multiple parts but the insect
exhibit is really varied there's like a
stream and trees and then you go into
like a butterfly area and you kind of
wrap around and it it feels like a real
Museum exhibit in a lot of ways the fish
one like you can walk up to a tank and
if you just kind of stop and look up at
it the camera might pan and show you
what's in the tank and just little
details like that really made it a
richer experience for me and the fossil
exhibit is especially cool because
there's kind of like guiding lines on
the ground that seem like they're trying
to mark like evolutionary lines and it
really it just feels like you're on a
museum tour going through that museum
you still have the
credible museum music that kind of puts
you in like a stoic mood and on top of
that it's more beautiful and more
impressive than it's ever been and I
just that was one of the first things
that struck me about New Horizons so
those are my impressions after 13 days
with Animal Crossing New Horizons
obviously I still have a lot to do and a
lot to see so I'm gonna keep playing
everyday as you do until I see those
things especially terraforming I can't
wait to see how that works anyway stay
tuned for the full review and for more
on Animal Crossing New Horizons
stay tuned to game spot
[Music]